[Music]
we've got more Rubin report YouTube week
in partnership with library today and
joining me is a social commentator a
failed musician and a mediocre gamer
some black guy welcome to the Rubin
report and thanks des for having me it's
great to be here surreal dude I took
that bio right out of your YouTube by
yeah so I don't want people to think
that I'm calling you a mediocre gamer as
we start because we've already talked
video games I suspect you know slightly
better than a mediocre game I'm I guess
I'm moderately ok but on the grand scale
of things when you watch pro gamers and
stuff I'm terrible you know can when you
really when you really think about it
yeah I'm pretty bad too - slightly tell
you that we have a bit of an age
difference here just the idea to me that
there are pro video gamers now like if
there had existed when I was closer to
your age man I mean that's what I would
have wanted to do right in a pro gamer
right yeah yeah definitely uh that's
something that I actually had some what
if I wanted to dabble in in it but I
remember I had a kind of slap into
reality when I bought it was the Marvel
vs. Capcom 3 back in like 2011 I started
playing online thinking that I was great
because I was great at the second one
yeah I think I won like two matches and
I lost like twenty that dude no no that
there's people that are just amazing
what system was that on that was on Xbox
360 that was on that and I was trying to
like say maybe if I can if I'm good here
then maybe I can compete and I couldn't
just beat your regular everyday people
that probably grind all the time same
thing with Call of Duty just there's
people are just too good men and then
it's not fun anymore that's the problem
right for these guys like they love it
they're great at it but then at some
point it's almost like everything with
our yeah someone in it when it stops
being fun it's it kind of sucks oh yeah
and that's something that it kind of
taken just taking a step back from it
and then having it be a hobby that
that's the best thing you really can't I
don't know if I i would probably love it
being a ha being pro and being in my job
but then at the same time then when it
becomes your job you lose that pureness
and that just the fun it'll probably
suck a lot of it out of it which I know
a lot of people feel that way about
YouTube to a certain
and we are gonna get into all of that
and much more you know I used to work I
don't want to brag but I was assistant
manager at Electronics Boutique which
you know I remember you guys know now
known as Game Stop and I remember by I
thought it was going to be like the
coolest job in the world I was right out
of college I was like oh I'm gonna be
like in the video game world yes selling
video games I thought it's gonna be so
awesome but selling video games and
playing video games very different
things like it was not nearly as fun as
playing video games oh yeah I imagine so
I actually tried to get a job in it
wasn't uh wasn't eb games but it was
game crazy they had games crazy and it
was for Hollywood video and my friend
got the job instead I don't know why I
don't I don't want to you know say
anything people were probably my fans
like the method or what you're implying
my fans like the message me but you know
where I'm going what they would probably
say but uh yeah he told me about how
ridiculous it was and people are always
trying to steal stuff yeah and one guy
actually he put it was when Xbox 360 was
brand new he put it on the counter dude
ran out with it Jesse's looked it and my
friend tried to chase after him and he
got fired because of it
I once tackled a guy that's really you a
dad I mean imagine going to electronics
blue team this guy just stole turbo tax
it wasn't even stealing something good
not even stealing like some car chase
game or something somebody should say
steal a turbo tackle I literally ran out
of store and tackled the guy I quit I
quit like I was like what am I doing
with my life alright wait let's rewind
for just a second so I intro you as as
some black guy yeah but you have a real
name I believe I need Derek yes and it's
funny because when I was doing a little
research
Derek Blackman came up and I thought
wait a minute now is his name really
Derek Blackman and he goes by some black
eye how do I ask this question because
YouTube's waiting to call me racist so
you're really so your name is Derek mr.
Blackman is not it's not it's an alias
it today yeah a lot of people you know
when they see that like wow is it really
black man like no unfortunately it's not
it's something that I just I like to put
out there because you know I don't like
people I don't mind people knowing my my
first and my last name my surname it's
pilot by the way like a regular
playing airplane pilot that's a cool
name yeah it's not mean it's pretty
unique I don't know other than like my
family and a couple other people I've
searched up my brother's like obsessed
with looking for other people with that
name but Derek pilot I mean you sound
like a video game character like Derek
pilot you know it gets totally work it
could I just I just put Blackman there
just take it plays off my name it also
there's uh there's a pro wrestler he's
uh he doesn't wrestle anymore his name
was Steve Blackman and I really liked
him he was a martial artist so I kind of
like always liked that last name
Blackman so it just I just put it in
there and it works and it's just like
you know it's kind of weird when people
are searching you and you know I have a
life of a lot of other things that I've
done a lot of other music projects and
everything and I didn't want people just
like looking for a that's fine if they
do but I just like hey Derrick Blackman
that's that's what you'll find if you're
looking for me anything that has to do
with YouTube you'll find Derek Blackman
it's so cool to me that like this
generation of people who grew up that
like made something out of the things
that I love so much I mean the things
that are here from you know all like the
sci-fi stuff and the video game stuff oh
yeah cartoons and wrestling and all that
stuff like that was all the stuff I
loved and it was just like a little bit
before YouTube although ironically we're
doing this on YouTube right now yeah but
you guys were able to like all make
careers that are talking about that
stuff and being in that world it's so
cool to me it's it dude it's not it's
surreal I still haven't fully processed
it even I one of my friends that one of
my like closest friends he was like dude
how does it feel that people are buying
shirts with your face on it and I'm like
I don't that's it's so crazy to me man
and I mean I I it's it's it's pretty
great though it's it's I I wouldn't have
any other way I love that that the
Internet has you know as gotten cave-ins
given so many people opportunities to do
things that they never even imagined
it's this and sky's the limit just gonna
keep growing from there yeah so alright
so some black guy yeah that's what you
came up with and I think it kinda you
know from all your videos that I watch
it does kind of caps lately you like
you're not trying to be holier-than-thou
you're trying to just kind of do your
thing and like you're some guy doing
this you happen to be black there yeah
how did you come up with that name like
was it just like one day you were like
that it was it was but it was back in
that on myspace days it was that was my
username probably when I was like 16 or
something it was just like oh you can
choose your name it was some black guy
and it really hit home when one of my
friends I added him and it said you know
he told me he laughed after he accepted
me it said that oh it says some black
guy wants to be your friend
so he thought I was pretty funny right
yeah and then I'll say you know this
this can I can use this for other things
I try to do a podcast like four years
ago and that was my alias some black guy
that thing failed and you know never see
the light of day but then it was that's
what it was like what should I call me
YouTube channel couldn't think of
anything some black guy then and it's
worked it people really seemed to like
it even when I said that you know what I
think I kind of want to change it maybe
I want to change but it's a Derrick
Blackman so it can be more of a personal
thing people can know me better if
you're like no you don't you dare change
it and it's also kind of an interesting
way of attacking identity politics which
we'll get into in a little bit but I
know you obviously don't like identity
politics so you're kind of throwing it
in their face yeah kind of right up
front which is which is pretty cool
let's talk a little bit about your
history that I think people don't know
about a little bit like just tell me a
little bit about where you're from
family that kind of stuff okay well I
initially I grew up in well I didn't
grow up and I was born in LA I was in
Inglewood and my father when he died
about then I was four years old I didn't
I didn't you know I didn't really know
what's going on so forcefully processing
everything and we moved to a North
Orange County like not like fancy OC
than the south it says regular might as
well be LA or a little part of some
people even called it like Mexico cos it
was La Habra Guadalajara people called
it and so this wasn't MTV OC definitely
not not even but that's what people
assumed if especially if they didn't
live in the area yeah and sometimes I
lived in Arizona a couple of times and I
tell people I'm from Orange County not
LA and like oh so you're so fancy and
I'm like no not at all dude not even a
little bit yeah but I grew up in there
and I was mainly I was interested in
just music and and there was a little
bit of sports but I got injured a few
times and when I was playing football
and I gave that up but I was always I
thought
I was always gonna do music I never
thought that I was gonna be like you
know speaking to people or like say
trying to entertain people in that way I
thought I was just gonna like try to
serenade people oh I try to be a
frontman I wanted to sing or do
something like that but I ended up
playing the drums more because drums
drummers were so scarce it was easy for
me to get a gig it was easy for me to
join into stuff like that and I mainly
played with like people can probably
tell I was more into like metal and punk
and that was always always a little bit
different because of just little things
I bumped into here and there and it
really kind of put me on that path of
like where I am now just always kind of
searching for alternative things and
like alternative thinking the certain
type of ways of thought and even in the
political realm or just do you have this
like left-right paradigm that was going
on and I just wasn't really as like I
don't really buying this stuff - to be
more things out there and then my friend
was tell me about what about independent
candidates and it kind of just
manifested from there yeah it's
interesting so you describe you're
obviously being tongue-in-cheek but into
your YouTube bio it says failed
musicians
yeah well that that was your first thing
now it's obviously the failure part of
that kind of led you to some success
here in the other world do you miss that
part though yeah dude I actually I've
been I've been kind of inspired to get
back into music I really I really wanted
to start making music again I always do
it on the side there is uh there's a
part of me on like Instagram I always
put up little clips of me I'll either be
seen playing the guitar and sometimes I
play the drums and people like you got
to do something and I just can't like I
just need a little bit of a push you
know but I do miss that and I say I say
failed musician because yeah I'm not I'm
not of touring or a career musician and
I got close I got close my this band
that I used to be in I quit and then
they soon after got signed to a major
record label but they fell apart - so
wouldn't matter in any way but I did
every once in a while I do get
recognized for being the drummer of that
band because you know it's a-okay in in
the metal in the metal genre how many
black people are in it
yeah you know so the black drummer and
have long braids at the time to be black
it's pretty interesting though but I do
I do miss plane and I might I sometimes
rap on the side but I might go on I
might do that because let's be honest
it's a little bit easier than trying to
get like a five piece 4 piece five piece
people together and try to have them all
work together it it it fails so many
times you know what I mean sure though
you do have a gig that's working right
now yeah this is this right now is
definitely paying the bills it's pretty
no I'm doing I'm definitely grateful for
it yeah so you know it's so interesting
so I have five youtubers on this week
and I should have asked everyone this
but I'll ask you this where do you think
talent actually comes from do you think
you were born with the musical talent
and the way you connect with people and
the humor and all that stuff or was this
like just through work and work I think
some of I think some of it is I think
there's certain aspects that are they're
kind of inherited that you're kind of
born with certain things like say I know
my family my mom and my dad they both
had a music year and it wasn't the
playing guitar was not natural for me
there was actually I was self-taught and
for a while I was playing guitar
completely wrong I was always playing
and standard and which is you know okay
you have your standard tuning which is
like you know 6e and I was playing it
like say what most metal musicians and
like the certain genres into they would
drop it
one down and it was that drop D and what
you can do is these bar chords and I was
playing it you don't do bar chords on
Ani I don't want to get too technical
but now I'm just saying that lightly
over my head yeah yeah people that play
a lot of people don't know what talking
about I was playing it wrong for a very
long time until I started you know
learning a little bit more so I
definitely wasn't just able to pick it
up and like I know what to do and I know
what everything sounds right but I put
in a little bit of work to where I can
play the guitar and the drums decent
enough to I could probably being a
successful band but yeah it's all about
work and so the talent aspect I think
there's some people that it's so much
easier but I didn't have like the I
didn't really have it just it wasn't
just a total like gift to me or whatever
I from a very young age I was performing
at I went to a private school and we'd
always have to do these performance
pieces we'd have to do like lip-synching
and all these different things that you
know your kid you hate doing this stuff
I didn't understand why I was doing it
but
it was it was essentially for the
parents right like it's just like
playing football and baseball and stuff
when you're a little kid you don't
really understand what's going on and
until you get older like okay I get it
now yeah and that's all that things it
kind of it worked it all the little doll
the singing and the dancing and all the
crap that I used to do it kind of
manifested into this you know now I feel
pretty comfortable in front of a camera
yeah well that's why I wanted to ask you
that because now when I watch yourself
it's like you strike me as like a pretty
full performer you know to me and like
you've got the tools and it's
interesting how you've kind of kind of
put them all in there when did you make
that shift to YouTube to YouTube
it was it was funny because I had a
channel that was not entertaining it all
back in 2010 where I was just talking
about politics it was more of us right I
mean uh well actually I also was talking
about cuz my first video was uh was
about religion or atheism because I kind
of got sucked into the the New Atheism
the you know the four horsemen and and
so I got sucked into that so I started
making some videos but then it just
quickly shipped into politics so there
was a lot of people especially there was
a lot of there wasn't a lot of black
people talking about politics in general
didn't matter where what side what
political you know affiliate or what a
partisanship you you you had it was just
people weren't really saying anything
and I was like you know what do not want
to like talk and see if people want to
listen and they kind of were they were
they were surprised that oh wow here's
this a young black man that's talking
about some really interesting stuff you
know where were your politics at that at
that time I was still I mean it's it's
kind of still words that were just more
like people call it a centrist now you
can say independent just more trying to
be left or right of center because I'm
just kind of like trying to be you know
figure things out and and I don't have
one just super left or right leaning
because there are some things that I'm
conservative bound there's some things
I'm liberal about and I think I mean I
think a regional perspective the best
way to go when you went on when it comes
down to it it's it reminds me of Chris
Rock where he had like a stand-up and he
was talking about things like no decent
person is just one thing you have some
things there that you're gonna tackle
the issue by issue case by case and
that's what I was trying to do when what
I whatever subject came up I was trying
to think of
rationally what's the best thing for me
or for the people and not just oh I'm on
the right or I am conservative therefore
I have to follow and abide by these
rules and like nonets I think that's
silly
yeah and it's just they draw us over the
head with this nonsense I always think
it's interesting on election day when
they're like well you know they show you
the map that got the big map and you
know John King at CNN is going in the
white working-class people voted this
way and the black inner-city people
voted this yeah but that's like that's
actually not really what happened here
yeah some of the they may
demographically it broke a little more
one way or another way partly having to
do with where you live or race but yeah
like just summing it up like that it's
like that's the stuff that separates us
that brings us together definitely
there's there's a part of like
collectivism that that is rampant more
like now more than ever and it's I feel
like the media they're trying their best
to keep it like that because it it keeps
you watching because conflict keeps you
watching right if everything is peaceful
and if everything is great you know
would you want to watch any any movie
would you want to play any games that
there was really nothing to do you know
no like there has to be something going
on that's why people click on the news
there's always bad stuff going on it's
not like hey this this person did
something very well or this happened
this happened maybe like that's like two
percent of the news so I feel like when
there is something going on kind of like
I talked about this in one of my videos
back in the day where the media calls it
the East Coast West Coast the rap or the
hip hop rivalry where it wasn't as bad
as it they made it out to be it had to
be the worst thing ever
and everybody's killing each other when
you know of course there were some
instances but I think that's what's
going on with with say that the
political divide especially when it
comes to just identity know that they're
trying so hard to make it that way and a
lot of people aren't just eating it up
how much does that suck for somebody
like you that puts out contrarian points
on this you know to me like if you're if
you not obviously I know plenty of black
conservatives and I'm not saying you in
and of yourself are saying you're
conservative but you have use all over
the place how much does that suck that
you have to put these points out there
and it just by the way the mainstream
treats everybody those are the
opposite points of what they would want
you to be saying you know yeah it's it's
really unfortunate and I like I find
it's it's unfortunate to me that I find
some of the stuff that I even say that
that I say is at all controversial
because I'm really not a controversial
person I don't say anything too crazy
yeah never really have maybe sometimes I
was like I'll just try to poke at people
too you know just for committee purposes
I'll say something maybe that's a little
derogative or something but as far as my
opinions go I think for the most part
they're pretty reasonable and and some
people are like how could you say that
how could you say that like that's not
the way it's supposed to be especially
since you're black you have to think
this way it has to be that way and and
I'm like why why I want to ask the
question why and a lot of times people
don't have the answer they just kind of
stop right there if I'm not mistaken
didn't Martin Luther King jr. wanted
black people to be judged by the color
of their skin right oh yeah I think I
think that was my maybe mixing something
up here like that is so lost that is so
lost nowadays especially there's a lot
of people that are I like to call a pro
black that are really just really into
their identity and people that would you
know really champion black lives matter
and probably would have been a part of
maybe the Black Panthers back in the day
who knows but uh they're the type of
people that even and I'm not saying
everybody it's just sometimes the
general stuff that I run into were if I
even mention something about Martin
Luther King jr. they would say something
like well Martin Luther King jr. didn't
always say then one time he said
something that kind of leaned more
towards what Malcolm X was saying like
yeah everyone someone not everybody's
gonna be a saint right sometimes people
are gonna have different opinions that
you know it might someone who might be
conflicted and say something but he had
his books he had he had a message in his
speeches they all they're all consistent
you know I think this is what he was
trying to say and like I don't know why
people are trying to undermine that it's
good stuff what what do you make of like
this constant thing in the media now
like from the HuffPo and BuzzFeed and
all that crap of like this endless
judging all white people in the same way
the same way you don't want to be judge
in that collective you
some videos on it you did a fun video
what was the last one you did a couple
weeks ago it's okay to be wider oh yeah
I was just trying to show how ridiculous
because some people are literally
treating it like that they see something
like it's okay to be white and they
think that's not worse than one of the
most harmless things you could really
say it's okay to be white like if
somebody came up to me and say hey it's
okay to be white I would just shrug my
shoulders back okay
have a good day um but people like oh my
god this is this is hate speech and the
Nazis are coming back in there they're
planting bases on the moon or so you
know like they're just being that crazy
being that crazy no they're not really
saying that that's something that um man
you guys see this movie called iron sky
and uh and play the new Wolfenstein I'll
just say that okay anyway
it's it's been I think that's been one
of the biggest problems and people are
trying to say that oh racism is rampant
because Donald Trump is president alike
no no no this anti white rhetoric this
is this the anti white rhetoric is has
come out before that it was one of the
reasons one of the reasons why I say
even something like gamergate was
happening where they were blaming like
say the you know you know everybody's
pretty much know about gaming and I
wouldn't say everybody but I think a lot
of your audience would know because I've
had a few people on about that but the
the mean that they were targeting say
straight white men that was like oh
these straight white men and and and why
did any politics was the worst thing
ever and you know people that want to be
proud of their heritage if they're white
or something like that it's it's the
worst thing meanwhile black people in
any other shade can do it and I'm like
well what's going on here like what's
really going on why is this happening
and I really I really I think it's just
a lot of white guilt yeah I think it
really comes down to it you see a lot of
people that are talking this way they
they feel ashamed for things that went
on back in the day and I'm like why why
do you feel ashamed for stuff that you
do why are you doing the sins of the
father thing yeah well that's what you
know Peter Bogosian who have had on a
couple times calls it a it's a secular
religion accepted in most religions
there's a Redemption narrative you can
be redeemed ah but with this thing
there's no redemption narrative unless
you're gonna color your skin which
actually would probably be racist it's
like the endless monster yeah
how much of this do you think is
actually related to gamergate without
without going too much into all the ins
and outs like everything that's
happening in society right now the
trolling Trump the media crumbling like
now it seems pretty clear to me this all
kind of started with gamergate is that
you think that's too much of a jump to
say um not really I think it's plausible
I think that it was kind of uh it was it
was kind of Pandora's box you know it
let out all the good in the bad yeah and
can you give like a 1-minute recap of
what you think gamergate okay Gary okay
so for the people for the people that
don't know gamergate is it was just you
had Pro and anti I'm just gonna say that
the the pro gamergaters was the
demographic the gamers the people that
play games that consume like gaming
journalism that that you know and then
you have the people that are actually
gamergate was the gaming that the game
developers and the games journalists and
essentially we learned that there was
corruption in there there was a lot of
collusion crude collusion sorry I can't
even speak right now there was just a
lot of a lot of shady deals going on
people sleeping with each other to gain
faith favors whatnot it got exposed and
instead of them you know a lot of the
games developers and the journalists
saying okay sorry we'll do better they
doubled down and started just crapping
on gamers and saying the age of the game
is over and it's just a bunch of
basement-dwelling straight white man
blah blah blah and gamergate is now a
harassment just trying to harass women
these gamers don't want women in the
video games and they don't want them
anywhere around and that's what
gamergate is and then pro gamer Gators
were like no we're just trying to have
journalistic integrity that's all yeah
that's basically what's going on it's a
clash of that stuff it was so
fascinating to me because you know I'm a
little out of my as I was telling before
I'm a little out of my like prime video
game years but I love the community I
love hearing about all this stuff and I
remember what gamergate was bubbling up
I was like I don't know exactly what's
going on here but it just felt like
something you know ii mean it felt like
something kind of important it was one
of the things that put milo on the map
and yeah plenty of other people but it's
so interesting to me that basically what
you're saying is that all the there was
the gaming community which of course is
black it's white it's gay it's straight
it's every friggin serious
it's the biggest media right now yeah
and they tried their response to being
exposed that because they were sleeping
with you know create developers were
sleeping with
with writers and they were paying off
people and all this stuff is that the
the industry decided to turn on its own
people which is such an you would think
how is that a logical move stupidest
thing ever
and that's what's happened and in a
weird way that is what's happening right
now with mainstream media constantly
telling white people how horrible they
are and it that's why I'm saying I I do
see a connection to where we're at right
now just in culture in general yeah it's
definitely and if it wasn't gamergate it
was just a phenomenon that happened like
say around the same time like a lot of
stuff in in a lot of different type of
media outlets we're all saying the same
type of stuff just anti-white rhetoric
and then it's so strange that if you say
something like well you know not all
white people racists or you should
really judge people on a case-by-case
basis you know individuality is probably
something we should champion like oh
you're just racist or like say me oh
you're you're just a bootlicking [ __ ] or
something and I'm like oh okay just
saying that we should you know respect
people or not respect people but at
least give people a chance judge them
you know on the content the character
that's that's me
tuning a I'm like wow okay any of the
people that say that kind of [ __ ] to you
are they ever not anonymous so actually
there's a there's a lot of them there
that are uh here's the thing there's a
lot the most of those type of comments I
get is from from black people right it's
from the the black community it's
usually the more stereotypical ones that
think that black means more of being
entrenched in hip-hop culture like
that's kind of what it means to be black
and you know when you think about the
grand scheme think about black people on
the world there are so many people that
aren't there's so many black people that
aren't black Americans and that aren't
into hip-hop culture because that's what
it's not black culture it's hip-hop
culture and you know they a lot of them
they're all about they're not about
anonymity they're about you know flexing
and they're about like talking [ __ ] yeah
that's interesting yeah so a lot of
times I've collected tweets I did a
video they got it got blocked because I
used some copier you know it was fair
use but it still got blocked use some
material but it was just showing
comments of people calling me a [ __ ] and
I would say 90% of people were black and
they weren't anonymous they that names
and pictures and they don't care
they think that you know death threats
man sometimes death threats uh there was
a saying that came from the sky I don't
even know if I just say him cuz you just
uh he says you probably know who he is
that tarik nasheed I don't know okay
yeah that's a big fan of mine yeah sure
he's called me a white supremacist of
course more than one of course he has I
wouldn't even have to of course you were
white supremacist a suspect suspected so
he doesn't get so it doesn't get in
legal trouble what a smart I'm like
which lets me know that I don't think I
think he's just playing people I
honestly for it to save people are
suspected white supremist are not just
outright saying you were white
supremacist I feel like he kind of knows
what he's doing he's playing this game
well it's funny because the last time I
came across him was a couple months ago
when he was tweeting about then Shapiro
being a white so in Orthodox are you
being a white yes yes and I just scream
captured it and I wrote okay this is
officially a parody account and I think
he either is he's either self parody or
if he's a troll he's a freakin high
level troll yeah but I don't know I
don't know what I don't know what he is
I don't even care it's like you're not
adding anything if you're high level
trolling I have no problem trolling but
you're not adding anything right now to
the discourse you're calling people
white supremacist ben shapiro me Phil
DeFranco plenty of other people that
better in our world and it's like oh
yeah and even if you're even if this is
a game to you nothing good is coming out
of it oh nothing at all it's really bad
and well it took my original point what
I was saying there was a quote that I
don't know where it came from but
somewhere within his media there's a
thing that's called Coons die first and
I've gotten that I think it has to do
with this Haitian Revolution if I'm not
I don't want to say 100 percent sure but
I think there was like people that were
considered Coons around there when
there's a revolution they killed them
too yeah and okay what do you how is
that connected how is it connected war
to me Tariq machine not we've we've
we've we've danced quite a bit yeah we
there's been a few back and forth sand
why I kind of think that he's not
completely genuine is because in one
breath you would say oh I'm just
scamming these white supremacists out of
their money the suspected white
supremacist out there money like I'm
aware that uh you guys are racist and
I'm just stealing your money and I'm
saying what you guys want to hear and
then yogi
you'll give me money to watch my videos
he'll say that but then in the next
breath he'll say that I'm denying that
white supremacy exists he's done that
he's attacked me on multiple occasions
you know he's had a stream about talking
about VidCon and talking about me
personally and some other youtubers and
he's he's a trip man and people his
audience would attack me and say really
crazy things and I even remember one of
them there was uh there was a tweet of
some dude just showing his gun on the
table like I'm like I'm like okay have
you been able to break through to any of
these people so the people that start
off with with the hate that then watch
your videos and go man these guys do it
every once in a while I'll see a a
comment and it's not usually until like
say I'll take the time out especially if
somebody comments on one of my other
social media outlets like say Instagram
or Twitter where it's not just a bunch
of cluttered comments on YouTube all
sometimes I'll talk to them I'll send
them a DM and I'll ask them like why do
you feel this way or why do you think
that all black people need to be this
way is it don't you think that it's
insulting that you're expected to act a
certain way you know like you don't even
think that's a little weird
and once I talk to sometimes they calm
down sometimes they think about because
a lot of people they're not thinking
they're just they're not thinking
critically at least they're not really
examining things they're just oh uh you
ask somebody what does it mean to be
black yes like ask a black person what
does it mean to be black pretty much a
lot of people don't really have the
answer to that it's so it's all
different I'm like that's exactly the
point you know it doesn't really mean
anything there is no just one defining
definition what it means to be black or
any other race for that and I would say
like hey how come white people there's
so many diverse there's diverse cultures
within a white communities where you can
be a surfer you can be a skater you can
be a musician all these different things
gonna be a business mogul it's all good
and then you know if you're black and if
you do a lot of those different things
it's kind of problematic it's weird like
say some people are being yo why you
dressed like that why do you listen that
and your heavy ass music you know might
because I like it what were you talking
about
I think that that's it like I don't have
any other answer like oh that's isn't
that weird I'm like do I like hip-hop
too no but I do
like other things that you're go to and
they're like I don't get it he's wearing
a Deadpool and a punk yeah this thing
and it's some funny thing about this uh
Bad Brains uh the these dudes are black
yeah no it's a pump in and these dudes
are black and I'm like yo yeah there are
black people that do other things than
just rap you know what I mean like
there's there's blue tzer's others
there's different things I mean there's
so many different things I make sure
there are no blues without black people
I say exactly exactly and it's just kind
of like dude think for a second like
just think no don't don't just and I
literally think that's like the problem
there's a lot of people aren't just
thinking critically and it doesn't you
don't have to be an intellectual
juggernaut to get a lot of things I'm
not the smartest guy I just like to
think things through and sometimes I'm
wrong but at least I'm trying
well let's unpack that a little bit as
one of those four horsemen you mentioned
oh he says unpack yeah
critical thinking where do you think
that came from within you because we are
in a major critical thinking deficit
these days that's actually something I'm
trying to well I wondered that myself
where I picked it up because from an
early age I actually was just able to I
was just I was just able to do it I was
you know with I used to go to church a
lot my I would go to my grandparents
house and they definitely tried to like
and talk to Nate mean to their dogma and
I wasn't buying it just from a very
young age it just didn't make sense to
me I couldn't I couldn't accept it it
just wasn't working for me
I remember my last time where I was like
I'm done I can't listen to this anymore
I'm just gonna sleep in church if I have
to go was when they were they were just
talking [ __ ] about Harry Potter being
you know tools for the devil and I was
like you know I know which crap I was
just like I can't I can't do this yeah I
can't I can't do it I I didn't when I
would see people praying and their and
they were saying certain it just didn't
make sense to me I didn't feel anything
and and then I started to just look at
things every everything like that I look
at everything when somebody told me
something outrageous I'm like where's
the proof you know even from as a kid
where kids would make extraordinary
claims about stuff because they're
trying to impress their friends and I'd
be like no that's BS dude like what are
you talking about yeah
with my rocket pack stuff like that word
bomb I used to I used to like I know how
to box I learned how to you know I'm
like a kid boxer and I used to you know
like yeah yeah well show me some moves
oh you know I just I just train at the
gym you know like not dude you just know
like let's just challenge people and and
and that's what I would just do think
about stuff and I can't really all I can
say is that maybe my mom putting me in
private school helped me that's the only
thing I can think of because we didn't
do a lot of like type of critical
thinking theory or anything like that
but they gave me some of the hardest
work that a kid like safe from an
elementary school should not be which
sitting have been learning because we
were I was reading these stupid articles
and I had to write papers on them every
day it was just like miniature book
reports every day I was doing
percentages and taxes and fractions Wow
yeah and I hated it I hated it but I can
at least say that I think it made me I
had to think so much harder to get it
I'd really had to understand and I
remember when I remember when I started
to understand stuff man is just a huge
just rush and a huge just you know
injection of endorphins dopamine right
like because I'm like dude I get it now
this is great and I always feel like
that when I finally understand something
and that's kind of I guess that that's
where I can really pinpoint it just
milia elementary school being challenged
to the point that I felt like I just
want I want to die when you were waking
up to some of this stuff related to
religion and all that how did the family
take it like your grandparents my
grandparents they definitely were they
were sad right because you know they
think I'm I'm damned they think that I'm
gonna go to hell my mom was a lot more
accepting she's like it is what it is
she didn't really like going to church
so much anyways but she's still very uh
very religious and I might get cooling
you know I'm gonna take that away from
her honor it doesn't matter if anybody
wants to talk you know we can talk I
never go out of my way to try to
challenge anybody and it was only my
grandparents that I really had the
problem and like I remember having
discussion with my grandfather and that
got up it was very rational it was very
I was just explaining my my grievances
and I was just without being if I ever
talking
somebody else that I don't really
respect is something I'll just
straight-up say like oh gods an [ __ ]
like there's no way there's no way
around it I'll just say and I'll explain
why but to him I was just rying to
explain it like that but very nice and
very calm and my grandma busted into the
door and starts saying well you know
you're either with us or you're against
us and I was like oh and she was like
you know you must hate yourself with
tattoos and all this stuff and I was
like where is this coming from
it was so strange and she was just you
know very fire and brimstone they're
very they're very they don't tolerate
anything like that and anything else is
just philosophy BS you know what I'm
saying like even like scientists right
and so it was it's that one that was
unfortunate have you been able to work
through any of that stuff yeah like
where's we're cool this was uh I think
this happened back in like 2009 mm-hmm
when when that was like that major and
we were kind of like we didn't talk that
much for a while even though I didn't
really have the problem I just kind of
felt like I don't know man it's I don't
want to like I just don't want to be
around the negativity right especially
knowing that behind my back they the
this is the type of stuff that they
think about me and you know I don't
really have I don't really
it's just it's just weird this is being
it's like being in a room and hanging
out with people that you know that don't
really that they think they they think
less of you yeah and it's kind of weird
it's like I'm not gonna just play
buddy-buddy and just be friendly just
because we're family you know like I
just feel like hey maybe we should maybe
something's wrong with their religion if
you if you if you lash out like that you
know I think that's a little I think
it's a little bad Hey to each their own
I guess yeah what about the skeptic
community in general because I'm kind of
welcomed in all these different
communities my way and I I think it's
simply just because I try to be
respectful of people so I've been
welcomed into the skeptic community a
bit and even with the Conservatives and
whatever sane liberals yeah it's the
progressives that don't like me pretty
much but the libertarians like I can
kind of bounce around which i think is
is really great at sort of what you were
saying before I think that's what most
people are we don't want to be just kind
of pinned as one thing yeah you have any
frustrations with the skeptic community
I see a lot of infighting lately
especially with the skeptic community on
YouTube yeah they're just attacking each
other constantly yeah I think there's a
lot of stuff going on one thing is I
think people are getting
they're kind of getting bored and
they're also losing sight of what we
should you know what we should really be
doing because there was a lot of talk
even months ago probably a half weather
year like say in the summer people
saying oh these pwnage videos these
social justice warrior videos and
responding to all this stuff it's all
they who cares anymore and I'm thinking
well this isn't over like this isn't
over dude like what are you talking
about you're getting bored so you had a
lot of people that were in fighting
about that oh you're just trying to do
this to get money or try to do this get
attention Oh some people aren't
intellectually stimulating enough like
we need people to be more like sargon or
something or there's some other
youtubers that are more like that
oh you don't have enough citations and
and then it becomes like there was just
a lot of attacks yeah and um and I well
you're one guy doing the best job you
can you're not CNN with you know
thousands of employees yeah I screw up
things all the time oh yeah and that's
the thing like I think that there's
people that are under a microscope
especially there's some people are
absolutely under a microscope and
they're people are waiting from them to
mess up and they're like oh I'm gonna
make a response video to this person
I'll look how stupid he is and I'm like
okay I'm Lee I guess I was entertaining
did it really do you feel better now did
it really help I see a lot of that or
it's fine I'm like if that's what you
want to do like I'm I've just I'm not
interested I'm not interested in the
infighting every once in a while I will
get sucked into some of the things that
get just a little bit stake too
escalated to a point where like I have
to talk about this this is what
everybody's talking about and I'm
interested too but there's a lot of
stuff that I have as far as the skeptic
community goes I try to just put aside
but every once in while I do get brought
into a conversation because you know
like it or not like I'm a part of it
yeah how much you think is just about
the desire for clicks like a lot of it I
see like someone on the rise and the
second they get to a certain point then
everyone starts going after them because
they just want the clicks that'll come
with the takedown which is a really
shitty way of that having public
discourse oh yeah that definitely
happens quite a bit cuz there's people
that like say me this this isn't my
end-all be-all job like I want this to
be one thing and I want to like spring
out do other things
yeah gonna be my last question okay
don't give me the whole answer to that I
will I was just saying
what I was trying to say is that I'm not
looking to I don't need to like say keep
attacking people to try to rise to the
top and keep going like look at me look
at me like there were certain people
there's still certain things going on
there's still some feminists being crazy
and you can do some certain things or
there's certain people that are having
issues and you can probably poke fun at
them and get really big and it's just
I'm like I'm not interested but there's
people that see it they see I mean if
you look at my most popular videos I
didn't want them to be my most popular
because like seriously let me give me a
couple of them well okay there's one
there's this girl she goes by the name
of superwoman on YouTube she's one of
the biggest her name's Lily she's one of
the biggest youtubers like I think the
last time I checked in the summer shell
I got 11 million subs no I made a video
because she was kind of being a little
bit rude and racist towards white people
just a little bit and so and she was
being kind of interested yeah so I made
a video response to her just thinking my
audience will enjoy this I'm just being
kind of rude back just be you know
that's my that's my comedy style just
gonna lose my stick right and man it got
like it's it's my second biggest video
it has like 600,000 views the lactose
liked racial last time I checked it was
20,000 20,000 like it was there was
people that loved her audience they oh
man it blew up now if I were smart I
would just keep doing like I'll let me
keep going after these big youtubers let
me let me keep I'm like listen that's
not I didn't I didn't intend it to be my
biggest video or talking about the N
word - the two times I talks about the N
word because of YouTube instances
they're like my biggest videos and
they're not my my favorite videos and
not my best videos it says me ranting
and giving my opinion like yeah this is
good and people are clicking you know
they're loving it yeah so as a free
speech critical think I it's interesting
that you just said the N word instead of
actually saying the word what's your
general policy on oh I mean it's all
good I just said it because number one I
even though I I don't care myself
there's a lot of people that do cringe
especially and I don't know how you feel
about like say I I try to keep you know
me you can say no absolutely I just try
to keep it classy right I tried for the
most part try to keep a classy there was
even let me tell you I wear shorts like
all the time and I was like you know
what dude I probably shouldn't wear
shorts here just
there is a farm I appreciate your
wearing pants
but like that even like I'm the I really
know I'm like doing whatever i ieave
enum sometimes when I go outside I'm
like oh wait I forgot that there's a
chance that somebody might recognize me
I should probably at least put on
something decent because I usually do it
I usually pretty I'm like ungroomed and
I have talons and stuff until I need to
go outside man where was I even going
with that well just as far as the n-word
and okay so yeah I just really like that
I'll say dude I'll say that I mean I
don't use like say I don't like I'm not
I'm not a person that use like [ __ ] or
or try Z I just say especially because
the algorithm purposes and everything
you put in word right so because if you
automatically if you put [ __ ] in the
in the title it's it nope you're not
getting monetized like no matter what
now there's something other than that I
will say it like say in the videos I'll
say I'll say it but it's just like
especially since the title it was called
like whatever breaking down the n-word
with whatever whatever the titles were
yeah are you worried about the way
intentions have been lost around the
conversation about the word itself like
when Bill Maher just a couple months ago
you know he said it oh yeah like in a
joking way I don't think anyone in their
right mind thinks that Bill Maher's a
racist but then next thing you know he
had to apologize yeah I sort of got the
smack down on his own show and I have no
doubt because Bill Maher has written
articles about stop apologizing liberals
I have no doubt that HBO said to him
you're fired if you don't oh yeah but
again no one really thinks he's racist
so does that worry you just as someone
that cares about critical thinking like
it it does it were it worries me
especially a lot of people really have
to tiptoe about a lot of things I mean
even like it even happened with
PewDiePie you know the same thing
well like say people I said on accident
Bill Maher was making a joke and some
people the audience laughed no they
thought it was funny right but no so
what's in calling anyone that didn't
know I would write he was using it in
there no he was exactly he wasn't using
drive-thru at all so I mean it's not
exactly the same but I was just saying
that it got the same reaction where
people were like calling for blood you
might come on
I saw comics that I know well you know
successful comics that are that are far
more famous than me
calling for him to be fired so I have
never heard of that before comics
calling other comics are the first ones
to advocate for a free free speech like
the first ones are like no do like the
no jokes are off-limits right that's how
it's supposed to be yeah that's what
it's so weird I feel like a lot of
people are just very signaling they
don't I feel like a lot of people don't
really believe that and maybe they just
want to score a few points and be looked
at in a in a better and virtuous light I
think there's a lot of people that are
acting that way because I mean
especially it being a comedian like how
could you say that how could you think
that you know especially there might be
it might be getting worse and worse and
so a time that like what jokes can you
tell now you know and I'm not I'm that
person I'm the type of person that yeah
as long as it's a joke it isn't like
nothing is off-limits you know because
there's a lot of people that love dark
humor doctor humor some of my favorite
George Carlin's probably my favorite
comedians like of all time right here oh
yeah so it's one of those things that in
a certain state it sucks that he's you
know he's dead but at the same time like
oh man yeah what would he be thinking
about this stuff that's going on now
he'd be losing his mind
yeah actually been a little bit of a
theme with a couple of the people that
we've talked to for YouTube week okay I
was talking to deal a call to gar and he
was saying how it's our we were
discussing how basically George Brown
has an old white guy right now what
would the reaction to him be on college
campuses saying all these words it would
not be good
no I don't depressing it is it is I
don't think he would be able to do it I
think um I remember Jerry Jerry Seinfeld
complaining just saying like oh man I'm
not doing colleges no one knows what any
of his political beliefs are yeah one
political belief the Jerry Seinfeld
holds that you can't you really can't
and it's it's so strange man and
especially college campuses in like
academia in general like what's going on
it's it's so mind-boggling yeah it it's
one of the you just had on Lauren bozer
named Lindsey chef Lindsey sorry yeah no
I said Lauren but yeah that's Lauren
time yeah okay
but I guess I got the L right yeah but
yeah it's just that whole situation and
it's thinking like yeah dude this is the
theme and this is what I was talking
about if I can just back up a little bit
yeah we were talking about the problems
and the skeptic community and stuff and
there are a lot of infighting and I'm
just thinking well you know there's a
lot of people there I think they're
they're not they're just not focusing on
there's some stuff still going on and
and I get it there's a lot of people
that do feel jaded I feel a little jaded
to a certain extent I do I've been
focusing a little bit on music and I've
been ramping up that but once I'm once
I've got that down I really want to
start focusing a lot more on that
because this is there's clearly a
problem especially in academia you know
a lot of the the crazy blue haired
feminists aren't making stupid videos
like they are like as much as they were
so that stuff has died down but there's
still articles and opinion pieces being
written things that you normally
shouldn't just you know maybe should
keep that opinion to yourself I mean you
can say it but like hey it's saying that
all men are toxic or all white people
are races I don't know maybe a Newsweek
or maybe a Washington journal or
something shouldn't really advocate for
that I'm just saying yeah you know I'm
glad you brought that back around
because you said that before about how
some people will say to you all the SJW
think is over we all get it now stop
doing videos about that now people say
that to me Dave you know you've already
everyone knows the left is a nightmare
and what's going on right now and
authoritarianism and collectivism and
all that stuff and it's like wait a
minute there are still people being
brainwashed at massive numbers right
colleges and universities and what the
academics are doing and all this stuff
so it's like yeah we get it
yeah the early adopters of the Internet
get it the gamergate people get it yeah
but when you get a win like we've had
some wins here like our our intellectual
allies or whatever you want to call it
we've had a couple wins here yeah you
don't just run and start trying to pick
a new fight then you have to make sure
your win
matters and that's why for me it's like
yeah I'll talk about all sorts of other
things too yeah but I'm not just putting
this thing down because a few people
seem to be on board with it now you know
and that's what people think I think in
their social bubble since a lot of
people that they know or wherever they
think that everything we're of it and
I'm like nah dude let's this lit that
stakes Facebook for example Facebook is
the you know the social media juggernaut
right
most people and they call you know it
maybe it's a little bit of a derogatory
term but normies right just regular
people that's the majority of Facebook
and the majority of Facebook doesn't
know about a lot of this stuff like if
you put out a video which I was telling
people you know a lot of people think
Facebook is really toxic and they don't
use it and I try to tell people my dude
use Facebook put those videos on
Facebook I used to neglect my YouTube
page I mean the YouTube my Facebook page
completely neglected and I started
posting my videos on there and I'm
putting a little bit of stuff out there
and it's doubled like the likes is
doubled in like say a couple of months
because there's a lot of people that
don't know about this stuff on there and
that's like that's what most people are
most people most adults older adults
people that are you know especially uh
people that are really old if they're on
the Internet at all they're they're
probably on Facebook yeah and then so
they publish to watch TV and and and
like a lot of news media they certainly
know they're MSNBC or fox or whatever
they're watching and then they might
possibly because maybe a grandkid or
something came across one of my videos
or somebody's video that does anything
similar they might come across you and
think like this is really interesting
I've never heard these type of opinions
I've never heard these perspectives
before and I think those are the that's
what needs to happen so I think getting
on facebook is as painful as it may seem
and it may be because I understand I see
a lot of garbage on there yeah but it's
always nice that like say hey even a
mildly innopolis his page picked up my
it's okay to be white thing and and
everyone's laughing and having a good
time like good that's that's what we
need you know taking the piss out of
this but people trying to make it so
serious and I'll just just laugh it off
dirt off your shoulder and and like if
everybody can be like that that's
fantastic
yeah do you worry that the certain
amount of young people right now come to
us whatever this thing is for news more
than their going to the old school news
like I'm happy that mainstream is
crumbling I think it's to crumble every
every week there's just another massive
thing just last week with this Brian
Ross story where he you know ABC News
they say that the that Trump ordered
Flynn as a candidate to contact Russia
and it turns out Noah wasn't as a
candidate it was as president-elect
which every president does and then they
retracted and it gets way less traction
than the original Arizona okay with
crumbling but do you worry that it's an
awful lot of pressure I mean you're just
some black guy oh yeah good point
especially there is a part of me that
wants to be more professional now wants
to do better that wants to anytime I
talk about something serious I want to
make sure I have my sources line up
because I've seen from a lot of people
or heard from a lot of people saying
like oh I get my information from you
guys yeah and and when I heard that does
it go that's that's that's not it's good
and bad it really is good and bad
because I'm not the I am not the arbiter
of truth or a lot of us aren't we're
trying I think that's what really
matters is that I really put emphasis on
trying that we're trying to be truthful
we try like integrity is important like
gamergate was all about integrity so
we're trying and I think that's better
like it you have better tools to find
the truth and and factual stuff and be
knowledgeable about things that really
matter then the major media that just
has a narrative you know they're just
gonna they're just gonna tell you what
what they want you to hear so I think
that is it's good and then there's some
people though like there's people that
are rising to the top that are putting
in the work that are being very
insightful you know we had the New
Atheism of the the four horsemen I think
very soon there's gonna be another
generation of that I think I don't want
to speak too soon but it's looking like
say Sargon you know Carl he's looking
like that type of person where he's
gonna be one of those and then there's
gonna be a few other people that are
gonna be along him and then you're gonna
see them sitting across from each other
and a table you know having discussions
and being that you know the new
generation of just the intellectual
minds and and and what were people that
people that are revered now I don't want
to completely blows you know I don't
want to completely all right you like
the guy yeah okay
he's cool he's good guy I'm just saying
no but it does show what's so cool about
this it's like I mean for me as an
interview I've gotten to meet so many of
these people and you know hang out with
some of them and become friends with
some of them and it's like something's
bringing us all together yeah it's like
that that desire for truth or to do the
best job we can you have some
intellectual honesty yeah it's bringing
us all together that's
who knows where it all goes and maybe
who where what in fact they're gonna be
with us all five years and all that but
yeah but right now it's pretty cool I
think
yet it definitely is it's um I've made
some I mean some people that I can
really I consider good friends because
of this stuff yeah just the social
circles I've been in and when we met up
at VidCon and then we're gonna be coming
VidCon we're gonna be doing our own
event called Kilroy yeah yeah I'm gonna
try to get there my schedule is a little
nut that's in April that's in April yeah
yeah so that's pretty cool I'll be a
part of that and to people that I'm
pretty close with there they started it
yeah and it's just like it the the stuff
started so that's Dave College Dave
Colin and yeah of computing forever and
then uh another youtuber that goes by
paste mama mm-hmm and she's one that's
really running the operation she's the
one that really put all together put all
four tuck it's all of her money invested
so much he's done it's amazing to see
and it just this morning when I woke up
it was just like 1% away from being
funded completely oh I saw I saw a tweet
about that yeah they were right there
like a couple right there yeah just
85,000 man and just like I think a month
or something yeah just showing you how
important free speech is to people and
how important this is and this is just
the beginning right who knows it might
be chaotic I have a feeling it's not
gonna be as you know ya know he's going
to be that inviting yeah it's gonna be
it's gonna be interesting there are some
people that definitely want it to fail
which is like why would you want a free
speech conference to fail like this
because there are some people that you
don't like they're my whole thing isn't
like dude yeah free speech affects
everyone like there's some there's
certain things like you might be next
right if you want to may have hate
speech laws in the United States your
your speech might be hate speech next I
mean I even think about um and the UK
cuz obviously they have some hp's laws
and there was this one I can't remember
her name but she was like a diversity
officer in this one University and she
had this one conference this club thing
that was excluding a white people and it
was only for like women of color and
then nobody else was allowed to be there
the diversity thing excluding white
people right
perfect and she also was a hashtag and
killer white men on on Twitter mm-hmm
she got arrested you know and I'm like
yeah you see how this is this is the
type of stuff you can you you your free
speech you don't have free speech either
you can't you can't be gross even though
like I know she literally doesn't she's
not gonna kill him why I mean we're
gonna do you're not gonna do that you're
just being a hateful bigot and she got
arrested for it and and I don't think
there's a lot of people that are being
hateful over here in the United States
but I don't think they should be
arrested for any other because you know
once it starts I hate the the slippery
slope argument but it essentially is
that we're if a lot of these social
justice words that the progressives
right are the regressives as people call
them you know if they were to get their
way there a lot of speech would be
clamped down and then certain things
that they're saying especially what
they're saying against white people they
would probably be next but that so
that's the irony that I don't think
people fully grasp right now yeah I'm
completely with you on that that right
now the right Trump and Senate I mean
the right is in power whatever that
means they're not coming for anybody's
free speech they're not yeah you know
Trump says some things that I don't like
oh yeah you know but he hasn't tried to
pass a law to clamp down anyone's free
speech I think it would be very
different if this crew was in charge of
what they would try to do about speech
because they would start labeling
everything hate speech start passing
laws Trump isn't doing that that's just
the fact it's an uncomfortable fact than
a bit of a weird fad yeah what I think
it's a fact it's one of the it's one of
the very small silver linings right
because there's a lot people like Oh
Trump won Oh hooray yeah but there's
some people that at least they were like
okay he that he's not he's not playing
into this social justice warrior Dogma
which is a lot of people voted for him
because of that there was other people
because he didn't look like he wanted up
blow up Russia like say Hillary Clinton
kind of was kind of seem like she really
wanted to do something about that I'm
like hey I don't wanna we publish it and
do that you know it it probably is
probably a bad idea
so you're saying you don't want to be a
war with Russia probably not it's
probably not a good idea like you know
we're dealing with proxy wars right
we're dealing with the Middle East we're
dealing with insurgents okay I think we
can try to get that under control we're
not having the best luck doing that we
been over there for quite a while I
think what Iraq's other Afghanistan's
like viana stands our longest war ever
something like 17 years something like
that some it's long it's really long I
don't quote me on that but yeah I'm like
dis yeah well it started in George W
Bush presidency so oh yes every day of
Obama presidency I don't know if it's 17
but yeah it's yeah it's definitely long
I don't do math later somebody can
correct me okay so uh yeah and just can
you imagine can you imagine like warring
with like another like a well developed
superpower that wouldn't that wouldn't
go that would be I mean you've played
Modern Warfare 2 right you play it play
it might be I don't think it'll get that
crazy but hey there's a glimpse of
something that could happen and so there
was a lot of people there was a lot of
liberals that I saw they were like dude
because of that because she people that
are so anti-war they're so against the
military-industrial complex they're like
I'm gonna have to get my vote to Trump
just to make sure she's not in office
that I was seeing stuff like that that
really fascinated me because I was
looking at I'm like this is know like
who are these people why are why is this
happening but to go back to the original
point though Trump definitely was uh he
was he wasn't there was a lot of
candidates that were also following the
oh we're gonna adhere to all the social
justice stuff even if they weren't even
so we like Gary Don Johnson until like
Gary Johnson did that and I was just
like dude what are you doing that
interview a guy Benson yes that was so
why like even if he believes that I'm
like dude just keep that yourself like
if you generally believe that like
that's you're offended by somebody
saying um illegal aliens make she be
yourself like really is it really a good
like what he doing the night that's a
part of that though was and I had guy
Benson sitting in that very chair huh
and I gave him a lot of credit for what
he did because at the end Karen Johnson
was like yes it's actually true
they're illegal so like you know and
that's what it is
when you're when you're making a point
that's not based in reality but just how
you feel
hmm well it's a good interviewer or
someone that you're challenging or
that's challenging you will eventually
get you to that place where you're like
you know it's all kind of [ __ ] yeah
and that's when I was like oh Gary
that sucks man because I was looking at
a I was on that Garry Johnson back in a
2008 and there was this website I can't
even remember what's called but I was
looking at a lot of the libertarian
candidates and also going to independent
uh parties and stuff and there was this
one libertarian website cam remember it
was called but it was um that was their
guy and he seemed pretty genuine but I
also was I was looking at Ron Paul a
little bit more and yeah his conviction
seemed like and his track record seemed
like it flawless like it was
unbelievable mm-hmm or like people were
trying to dig out dirt on him they
couldn't find anything yeah and I was
thinking even though like I'm sure
there's a lot of people they're like oh
he's a creationist like and and he
specifically said hey uh what I believe
is gonna affect my job just like it
doesn't when you normally when you're at
your computer desk or whatever you're
doing you're digging ditches does your
beliefs affect what you're doing and I
was like I can live with that I was
seeing some pretty interesting things
going on it's also an ob/gyn yes and as
an eye doctor I mean these are people
who believe in science oh yeah yeah he's
not just some really easy doc he's
delivered thousands of babies I mean
he's he's not he's a he's a war veteran
he was a he seemed like a pretty genuine
guy and I was just really blown away
with the type of the alternative
candidates and I was thinking why aren't
we looking at these people and then I I
quickly you know saw why there was just
the media influence and the lobbying and
stuff that you saw like you looked at
the major candidates that are always at
the forefront and they're being backed
by the major banks like Goldman Sachs
it's it's shoveling money to them
knowing that oh these be the banks are
gonna be the winners you know these
people are really overall they're gonna
get all the tax cuts and all the waivers
and everything if they're gonna make
sure that all of them there they're
there they're doing well and I was I was
starting to understand what was
happening so I was I became extremely
jaded about politics in general I may go
and all I'm seeing the candidates now
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton like
how did we get here
how did we get here like where this is a
thing but I will say Trump winning did
there was there is a good thing because
a lot of people believe that the system
was completely corrupted everybody
everyone thought Hillary Clinton was
gonna win everyone I mean watching i
watch ben shapiro talk about even though
on your show here
everybody was wrong everybody was I made
a prediction back in 2015 that like Oh
Bernie Sanders doesn't have a stand a
chance it's gonna be the same thing like
Ron Paul or anybody else it's gonna be
blacklisted from the debates gonna get
no time to speak that's obvious and then
I was thinking Oh Hillary Clinton gonna
pull it out because she has all the
influence niche and then that's what the
media said didn't work that was the
strangest thing man
yeah that's at the night of the election
I was on a daily wire live stream with
Shapiro and Clavin and a couple other
people that's exactly what Clavin said
and it really helped crystallize it for
me it's like if you think that the thing
is so corrupt and corroded and evil then
the best thing just happened because the
thing that nobody thought could happen
and that shows you that the corrosion is
in permanent yeah corrosion is actually
weak so I'm actually quite hopeful I
sense you are right now yeah you're
actually hopeful for some ideas
absolutely right now yeah absolutely
there's something in and then now you're
seeing other people that and because
it's UMP you seeing other people like
you know I might run to and and I might
good the more the merrier we need a
diverse line of people running I mean
even somebody like the rock Dwayne
Johnson says he's thinking about running
I that's hilarious right cuz I'll be the
rock versus Mark Cuban that I mean the
funny thing is the way that I even look
at it it has it's been like kind of a
charade in this [ __ ] show I wouldn't
mind seeing it just really just just
just make it as crazy as possible so we
can like out after a while you know it's
so chaotic and then we kind of maybe
start bringing some like what do you
call like order out of chaos kind of a
thing like that I think something like
that could happen where things get so
wacky that it might even be yeah the
rock and then his VP is Stone Cold Steve
Austin is something does ridiculous and
my child I would just be like man I
don't want to be one of those people but
I might I might throw them a vote just
just because of you know let's see what
happens and and then after a while maybe
like okay this needs to stop let's get
some legitimate candidates here cuz this
is getting too crazy America the United
States is embarrassing I mean we're kind
of ready they're right I personally
would prefer Jake the snake Roberts
instead of accept that so all right the
last question which you already started
answering before where do you want to go
with all this well is is YouTube in this
digital world enough do you want some
mainstream stuff do you want to shift
what you're doing
well new YouTube kind of is enough right
now like say it's sustainable even
though there's been problems at the ad
pocalypse and everything like that
however you hit pretty bad my revenue
was I think it was a cut like 3/4 3/4
Wow
yeah so it was it was pretty bad but
luckily around the time that that
happened I had a lot of patreon support
and now that the ads started getting
better the patreon support was dwindling
it started to kind of balance out a
little bit which is you know totally
fine it's okay right now but it's it's
I'm a little worried just because things
are you know like the mainstream media
is still doing their best to make sure
that youtubers get hit because they're
losing a lot of their revenue yeah do
you notice how every time they want to
throw someone under the bus that's a
creator in our world they always attack
patreon now yeah every article about
Jordan Peterson who's the new target for
them oh he's going after patreon yeah
when they've done it to me always going
after patreon and I'm sure many other
people to it so because they want to go
for the money they can't get you on the
ideas yeah they do go for the money and
like so you can't you can't sustain
yourself anymore and it's such a dirty
it's such a disgusting tactic man you
think about like these are these are
people these are their livelihoods
livelihoods and and and I think about
the people that work in like safe
special in the Wall Street Journal
trying to like attack PewDiePie and I
think that the people that are around
there I'm like dude do you guys have any
any empathy whatsoever do you have
you're trying to not only you're not a
folk a PewDiePie as a millionaire but
what about the other people that affect
it a bunch of people that were like you
know I can't do this anymore
you know do you have any remorse
whatsoever I'm like what's the matter
with you but for right now it's it's
okay right now it's okay I want to keep
doing this but I definitely want to
shift into music I've been a little bit
conflicted with that in which way I
should go because I love metal and also
love hip hop and that's been like the
biggest thing like what should I where
should I go I'm leaning more towards hip
hop just because it's it's more of an
independent thing I can just write my
own stuff get some beats I can go to a
studio and record from pretty much
anywhere bands differently as a white
person I'd be much more comfortable if
you were doing hip hop it wouldn't
challenge
I mean at least the type of hip-hop I'm
like I'm like that do Drake right I'm
like Drake and this dude Kid Cudi where
they talk a lot about personal issues
and their feelings I'm that guy yeah I'm
that guy that stuff that I recorded I
talk about a lot of breakups and
relationships I'm not gonna be the guy
that's talking about pistol grip pumps
I'll be talking about lowriders nothing
like that you know even though I love
like gangster rap dude it's it's um it
sounds so delicious man it's so good
well I feel like on your way out of here
today so as we're taping this right now
this is going up in a couple days yeah
we're taping this right now la is on
fire I mean right here I mean it smells
like smoke in here right now or there's
these massive wildfires you're gonna be
driving home back to OC yeah no some of
it so I feel like there's a song in
there somewhere you know what I mean
they're come up with some definitely I
mean if I you say that because I
actually wrote a song already it's a
it's called SoCal he like you know some
California and I wrote a song and it's
actually just parts of Orange County LA
it's all included in their little cute
things in there and I'm gonna um I
recorded it a long time ago but I'm
gonna rerecord it and I think that it's
basically what you're saying and I think
it could do pretty well man um we'll see
what happens though I it could be can
totally bomb my I don't want to be
confident I don't want to I don't want
to like to my home so it's gonna be good
right I'm gonna put it out there and
just hope that it does well well that's
it just I'm gonna I'm always gonna do
YouTube as a hobby I'm always gonna be
putting out videos I because this stuff
matters to me I started doing this
because I originally wanted to be a
gamer I wanted I saw like PewDiePie
markiplier ksi so all these people
making a lot of money in this using
their personality playing games I want
to be that and that's how I somewhat
upon gamergate just seeing the climate
that was on YouTube and that's what
everybody was talking about and then I
felt kind of morally obligated to say
something knowing that I wasn't gonna
get anything out of it and I just kind
of got lucky right yeah and then I still
feel like there's a part of me that
always as long as this is happening I'm
gonna be saying something because I
initially just want people to chill out
I just want to play my video games read
articles watch movies and stuff and not
hear about all this identity politics
nonsense you know there's a lot of
things out there that aren't tainted
like say Pro Wrestling I still watch and
I can still I can still watch I can
still read articles and I'm not blasted
by white supremacy or this so there's a
lack of this you know so I just want
that dude that's really what I want and
then other people that are trying to do
more in affect policy man go for it I'm
all for it
awesome well I'm thrilled that you came
in here and I'm a fan of what you do I'm
gonna donate to your patreon okay I'm
going to do it today I think I only
donate to to others but you will be you
will be number three really and I think
you have a ton of you know great stuff
in front of you so you don't need me to
say that though oh man did I appreciate
that that that's so that's so surreal
man it's silly it's crazy like I'm
telling you like in the beginning said
being here is so surreal like seeing
this and I'm like wow I'm here and I
never thought cuz I've been watching for
quite a while man I knew you wanna I
knew you wanna the Young Turks seed oh
it's so like [ __ ] we'll do a bonus
segment on that okay Thank You Man I
appreciate this so much
yeah awesome all right for more with
Derek Blackmon check out youtube.com
slash some black
[Music]
you